it's the news we've been waiting for the
strike is over and I've got up on this
lovely sunny Thursday morning to read
the news news that I've been expecting
for a few days CU be honest my sources
told me this was actually going to be
over uh Tuesday but it ran over a little
bit but it's over now and
congratulations to all the members of
sag after out there that have really put
their asses on the line to get this deal
done welcome to serek your SciFi TV
movie
[Music]
channel so yes it's the news we've been
waiting for and it is good news the
actors should be able to get back to
work really quickly hopefully within the
next couple of weeks the studios did set
this deadline of November 1st not Disney
and Netflix Unfortunately they are the
main reasons why this has took a bit
longer than hoped but the smaller
Studios did really desperately want to
get done by now because basically they
need to get all the movies for next year
up and running they need to get a load
of projects for the new season of
Television up and running they were
hoping to get a load of stuff done for
Christmas that is now going to be
pushing it but we might see some Live
Events and things now that we wouldn't
have been getting otherwise but all of
these things that the particularly the
smaller Studios again not Disney and
Netflix they're not as bothered
apparently Disney would just obsessed
with AI That's all they've really been
dealing with apparently they've invested
a lot of money in AI over the last few
decades and a big problem they've had in
the last few days in particular was that
um Disney went over every line of the AI
deal with a fine tooth comb and that
just took forever but it does look like
like we're getting a bunch of safeguards
for AI it does look like Saga have got a
lot of the financial package that they
were hoping to get and it does look like
we're going to be able to get back to
work movies television
awesomeness how quickly well I'm being
told that there's already several big
projects that were put on pause during
the strikes that are already um they've
got people in the
studios getting the sets ready getting
the electrics all turned back on they've
already been looking at getting the food
trucks in and blah blah blah all of the
boring mundane stuff that has to be done
if you want to do a television program
or that is being done anything that's
being done sort of outside on location
you know local councils Etc all of those
permits are being applied for basically
all of the background stuff was started
to get done a couple of weeks ago so all
of those projects should be up and
running reasonably quickly I've actually
heard and I told you a couple of days
ago about the alien franchise TV show
that's being filmed in Thailand
Apparently that is ready to go and the
second the actors could be recalled
they'll be on a plane so that should be
up and running again within a few days
even in theory they could get back to
work next week from Friday basically
when this is ratified by the members of
sagaa they could get back to work so
this can be really quick
um the writers Etc have been working for
a while there are a few projects like
Daredevil that they're actually scrapped
and completely rewriting so that
probably will take a little bit longer
but how about new projects well I am
told by a source that works at one of
the major um creative and talent
agencies that actually conversations
have been going on for quite a while um
really it was never against Agra rules
for the agents to talk to the studios
and the studios to talk to the agents
and the Agents to talk to their clients
as long as it wasn't about upcoming
projects so I hear there's been a lot of
sort of like coded conversations going
on for a few weeks because they knew
this was coming at the end of the day
they knew that they knew the strike was
going to end at some point right so they
knew this was goinging a lot of coded
conversations have been going on and
basically from really tomorrow they will
be able to have those straight
conversations right the studio wants you
for this sign this contract you know
that thing that we mentioned about the
thing that will happen very quickly and
we should start getting some
announcements very quickly what does
that mean for Stargate because you know
we mentioned that here on this channel
occasionally well I'm told that there
was always the three things that MGM and
Amazon desperately wanted for Stargate a
writer a director and a star somebody to
be signed on obviously they couldn't
sign anyone on until the strikes were
done now they can I am told there has
been several different conversations
with actors we don't know who they are
yet we think Amanda Tappen and Michael
Shanks but anyone else they would be
able to sign on from next week so in
theory we really are looking at any
minute that Amazon and MGM could have
the three things the triactor of things
that they want before they make an
announcement ideally so who knows it
really could be any day now
it's been a long road getting from there
to here i' I'll stop but it has been a
long road but we're there thank God but
get into the comments tell me what you
think is this going to be a good deal we
should find the details on the deal
tomorrow how the delays mainly caused by
Disney a concern and what do you think
generally is going to happen in 3 years
time when this contract is going to be
negotiated
again get into the comments tell me
exactly what you think if you're new to
the channel like subscribe hit the Bell
notification you know what to do also
got a patreon.com sidre where we Premier
a lot of our videos first also go to
s.co which is our dedicated website and
we do articles based on a lot of our
videos with a little bit more detail for
you to digest go check it out right I
suppose I better turn on the laptop
wherever it is it's here somewhere and
do my proper
job I got day we've had nothing but rain
that's
glorious as always stay safe I'll see
you
[Music]
soon